في عيد ميلاد جوجل الخامس والعشرين سئل
الامريكيون كيف يرون محرك البحث الاكثر
شهره في العالم وما مدى تاثيره في حياتهم
قال بعضهم ان الشركه غيرت العالم حيث وفرت
الوصول الفوريه الى المعلومات فاضحى كل
ذلك في متناولنا
اعتقد ان جوجل قد غيرت العالم وغيرت
الطريقه التي نتواصل بها والطريقه التي
نتحدث بها مع الناس وكيف ننجز الامور وكيف
نعالج المعلومات
يتعين علينا جيل السبعينيات والستينيات
اجراء استفسارات في المكتبات العامه ومحل
بيع الكتب مازلنا نقرا الكتب على الورق
لكن جوجل غيرت كل شيء بالكامل ولم يعد
المرء بحاجه الى التنقل فكل شيء في
المتناول
تق جوجل او خرائط جوجل تقويم جوجل لتنظيم
جدول مواعيدي كتحديد موعد مع الطبيب او
معرفه اوقات قضاء الوقت مع الاصدقاء او
معرفه مكان صفي وساعات العمل بينما اسست
الشركه في الرابع من سبتمبر عام 98 فانها
تحتفل بالذكرى السنويه لتاسيسها في السابع
والعشرين من سبتمبر بدا ذلك عام 2005
ويمثل تاريخ اعلاني عدد الصفحات التي كان
جوجل يفهرسها ما بدا مشروعا بحثيا لكل من
لاري بيتش
من غرفه سكنهما عندما كان طالبي دكتوراه
في جامعه ستانفورد اواخر التسعينيات تحول
الى شركه تكنولوجيا متعدده الجنسيات مع
اقسام تغطي التجاره الالكترونيه والاعلان
الرقميه ومنتجات التكنولوجيا والذكاء
الصناعي وغير ذلك
يمتد استخدام محرك بحث جوجل الى جميع
الاعمار ويعالج نحو اربعه مليارات عمليه
بحث يوميا ويمتلك بذلك نسبه 92% من الحصه
السوقيه العالميه لمحركات البحث ما جعله
الموقع الاكثر زياره في العالم